what do you do for a living oh my God
you're so sweet are you crying
no that's actually kind of I'm asking
pretty innocent questions right now I
know I just asked what you do for a
living and you got emotional that's wild
you can't be falling apart like that
somebody asked what you do for a living
you start tearing up that's nuts come on
now what do you do for a living
education I knew what I felt it from you
have such a teacher energy and this is
your boyfriend of a couple years you
guys think about it getting married son
this [__] slurping cheese and
it's not gonna ask that question
hard dog he's
damn dude I didn't know I was gonna
scare you like that I'm just talking
innocently it's been a couple years God
damn how much you gonna cry when you
propose it's gonna be on it's gonna be
obnoxious and you might even get a
little bit put off you might be like all
right cut that [__] out